like learning a second because like
obviously we've all had second languages
that we've never really learned yeah has
learning like a third language for you
made you appreciate welsh more hundred
percent
100 100
straight up no no really like yeah for
sure like i you know i take it for
granted but then again like i also feel
like god i've like i never ever wanted
to learn in my mind i always said of the
mindset of like you know i know this is
very close minded but i was just like
i'm just gonna let's speak english i
already know the language i thought that
way right yeah and and i i still to this
day i hate learning languages yeah yeah
i'm [ __ ] trying to learn a third the
[ __ ] is that what's up with that what's
up with that man i want to learn a third
language i just don't really have the
time right now the problem i mean that's
right is that you
like unless you're like one of those
people who's just obsessed with
languages and learning them like i feel
like you will only learn the other
language if you need to yeah yeah which
is the only reason why i'm doing it like
i'm i'm finally at a point where i know
people like online they always don't
know how you're japanese and stuff and
it's so hard to convey how you're
japanese is when you don't need to speak
it yeah i don't want to speak it online
sometimes because it's embarrassing like
you know like chris will always try and
get my [ __ ] japanese out i know why
chris is [ __ ] doing it because he
wants to feel good about his chest
as a [ __ ] because obviously
obviously chris's japanese is better
than mine yeah yeah like not by much
though
when i see chris yes he has no problem
conveying a lot of like thoughts
when i'm with him he'll do anything he
can to not speak japanese because he's
just cause he's all the same it's it's
like the same
thing he doesn't want to do it in front
of you because it's embarrassing because
he's gonna feel like i've been here for
eight years i should speak better yeah
yeah and like yeah like you know it's
whatever whatever amount you want to
learn you can learn i'm i'm even though
i want to i want to get better yeah i've
gotten to a point now where i can pretty
much do everything except for do
government documents i can everything is
not appropriate i can barely do this
yeah so i can go to the bank that's how
that's
my fluency is increasing it's somebody
who came here literally no nothing i'm
pretty proud of where i've come from
like how far i've come but like you know
it is again it's it [ __ ] sucks online
yeah people oh yeah people are [ __ ]
because because people people expect you
to like reach a certain level by a
certain time sometimes i forget what
sometimes i forget a word that i should
know sometimes i forget an easy one
i'm exactly the same where like it's i
was putting in hours like every single
day for like a good good like two three
month periods yeah um and then i went
back to england right and it's it's like
going to the gym where you like build up
this uh
you build up this routine and you're
like great i'm doing this routine and
then something comes along to [ __ ] over
that routine and then like it just
cascades and you miss a day and then you
miss two days and then you miss a week
and you're like [ __ ] now i'm starting to
forget you know
and like that's that's where i've i'm at
now where like i was making such good
progress and then i went to england and
then it just cascaded and i'm like
trying to have to put the effort and to
relearn some of the stuff that i knew
before and now i just forgotten because
i wasn't putting the active hours in
every day yeah i've i've speaking of jim
i have really [ __ ] struggled to get
back into it like it is hard i forgot
how hard it was to get back into the gym
if you fall out yeah because you know
when you're going every week you don't
really get sore the next day much it
doesn't really happen because you're
probably eating the right thing your
body's used to you doing it yeah and
like i i didn't i rarely got like very
sore yeah now when i go i'm sore for
like four days because i haven't got a
month right so you combine that with
like
also having a busy schedule and i want
to go more but you need to go at least
once a week or more to kind of build it
up right yeah but now if i'm sore for
four days i'm not gonna go for those
four days and then i gotta pray that my
schedule isn't full on the other two
days that i i'm able and i want to go
but of course life isn't like that most
of the time it's i'm doing something i
gotta go somewhere yeah so it's like
[ __ ] man like i'm i'm i'm really trying
to get back into this but it is so
goddamn hard to get back into the gym as
an adult when you fall out of it yeah it
is so difficult because most people just
aren't used to making a lot of time for
it and it's something that i i will not
i will not empty my schedule to go to
the gym no no i to me it's like i i know
i should say i should exercise i enjoy
it i really i really love going
but i want to do everything else first
yeah i want to prioritize my work first
yeah and then i'll go to the gym
i mean it's it's it's what it's you know
it's just being an adult right have you
signed up to a gym sorry i have not
signed up
i mean i mean like
are you going to probably not i kind of
like i kind of had this realization
where the little free time that we have
to work with i'm either going to go to
the gym or i'm going to use that to
learn japanese and i chose like i made i
made the active choice to be like i'm
going to put whatever free time i have
into learning japanese that's my choice
because i'm not like i before i was like
i can do both i've got time to do both
and then what i realized is that i
didn't have time to do both and by
trying to do both i didn't i didn't
either exactly and so i like i knew i
needed to like because the thing is
either with gym or language learning i
think discipline is the most important
thing like it's like it's it's
the idea is nice so i feel like you're
going to the gym every week or every day
or putting an hour of whatever you want
into learning japanese but it's not
going to happen if you're not going to
like commit to it yeah yeah and you need
to just be like strict with yourself to
be like i'm going to put up
i'm going to this is going to go beyond
me just having this idea of i wanting to
do this thing and me just putting in
like the raw hours to do it
i i think one thing that i uh took this
is from tyler1 stream as well right of
course is what he said right and
honestly i it really resonated with me
he he said that like he goes to the gym
a bunch right obviously because he's an
absolute human machine you haven't seen
tyler1 this man is literally like insane
yeah he was like and to this day this
like i still firmly believe this he was
like you know even if you have the
shittest day on earth if you go to the
gym and you work out you've done
something yeah you actively feel like
you've you've you've made some progress
on something yeah and like you know work
doesn't have to go right your
relationships don't have to go right
right but at least you've had that one
thing that you've done that was good for
you yeah and and it and it and and to be
honest right when you go to the gym like
the one thing i really loved about it
and and this is probably the reason i go
is because the the the day so i i like
to go in the morning yeah i don't really
like going at night it's not really my
thing
when i go to the gym in the morning that
the the rest of the day is like amazing
like my energy's high i feel great the
next i sleep well i normally have a good
next day too as well so i just find that
everything improves when i go so that's
why i do like going yeah the [ __ ] is it
hard to do it oh yeah i mean like i i
like this year i opted to
get up at like you know around like
eight or nine a.m nine a.m later i've
been doing that as well yeah and just
like even if like i got barely any
[ __ ] sleep the night before even if i
went to bed at like 3 a.m yeah i always
try and get up at least like 9 a.m
latest just because i know that in
between 9 a.m and lunch if i get
something done before lunch i feel
[ __ ] amazing
i'm like
it's i got something done it's not even
lunch time yeah it's such a dude we're
all like synced up yeah it's such a
matrix thing yeah it's such a simple
life hack where yeah like like waking up
early pack wake up early all the adults
tell you oh you'll feel better if you
wake up early as a kid i'm like shut up
let me stay up to date with you [ __ ] you
let me stay up till 5am playing video
games
see how that hurts me i know who knew
that it hurt you yeah
the one good thing right about okay
there's two sides of this coin
so if you are waking up at nine all the
time even if you go to bed like five a.m
you have like a night out you'll
probably still wake up at nine because
your body's like this is this is time to
wake up get up now yeah and i have been
yeah you feel [ __ ] all day yeah but at
least you still maintain the sleep
schedule yeah i mean yeah but on the
other side i remember when i used to
wake up at like 1 or 2 p.m it's not my
proudest of days yeah i think we've all
been there i would wake up at this time
one good thing was that
one i normally just like didn't eat as
much like i found that when i'm awake
all day i'm eating a lot more mm-hmm
that's good or bad i wonder why yeah
yeah i'm just i've got more [ __ ] to do
i'm more active but i would eat less
because i would just eat a meal at like
eight and then i would go to bed yeah
yeah at 4am or whatever yeah but
the other thing is when i go out with my
friends and we're going drinking i'm
getting really tired by like 10. and i'm
like [ __ ] bro i remember when i would
wake up at two and we went out yeah i'd
be like four am you both good i'm still
good to go man yeah let's go let's party
let's keep going yeah and everyone's
like i'm so tired i gotta work tomorrow
i'm like let's keep going let's keep
going no and then now i'm that guy who's
like dude it's like it's like 9 p.m man
i uh i gotta get back soon you know
yeah it's so sad man i can't i it's so
hard for me i remember yeah i remember
when i first like when we first started
coming to japan like me and joey had
this thing where every time i would come
we would do like all night karaoke
every time every single [ __ ] time and
then like twice a week we're gonna have
to do that when people come here you
know that right now
i'm dreading oh my god i'm like can we
go in the morning and just go all the
way to like 10 p.m and this is cool
content creators who want to come on
trash taste who are mutuals with us on
twitter there's a very very small amount
of people watching this yeah yeah if you
come here please don't all come at the
same time
i'm pleased we're gonna die
it's gonna happen though when the
country opens up there's just gonna be
like a mass [ __ ]
[ __ ] people just coming in the
country yeah like i saw people on
twitter were like talking they were like
any other content creators want to
arrange a trip to japan when it opens up
right away and i was like please don't
always
that morning that train home or that
taxi home or that whatever however the
[ __ ] you get home is like the most
depressing thing
in the world dude when i was coming back
from your housewarming party it was like
like 2 a.m on a taxi and i'm like
god i want to die
i was like it was the most depressing
taxation i've been on so long there's
just something about going home after a
night out when you can see the sun that
is just like that
that is like what am i doing i'm like
you're walking you're walking in the
streets and you're just like
everyone else is going to work yeah are
you like look at all these people with
an adequate amount of sleep in their
body
[ __ ] them i feel hopeless
oh my god yeah i remember that i used to
go out to like 4 a.m when we first came
to me like we used to do it on the on a
whim but now like it needs to be yeah
i gotta like go to sleep really early
the night before so i can get like
enough sleep before my waking up at 8 am
yeah oh my god no because like for me i
i i luckily like if i want to stay up i
can stay up really easily but what that
just means is i just lose a day it's
just i i lose a day if i stay up late
now it's
like
my actions have
consequences who [ __ ] knew it's this
[ __ ] who's last alive he's
always the one up until like seven how
do you get it at like two sometimes i
you know
i don't really get much fomo anymore at
parties i don't really feel like i have
to stay up once i'm done i'm like later
guys if i'm the first to go to sleep i'm
the first to go oh yeah i'm no qualms
about it it's whatever my body's saying
i'm like all right later guys yeah cause
i especially if especially if i'm i need
to do something the next day or they
want to hang out again the next day yeah
i wanna i wanna be awake to like spend
time with you guys yeah of course yeah
exactly yeah yeah we might dance like i
must stay awake
i don't know it's just when people are
there i'm just like i i wish just i wish
to converse now i wish the social sure
that's the thing right it's like it's
like if i
if it's just like a regular night right
yeah and i'm like i could stay up and do
whatever i'm doing until like 4am but
then i think to myself i'm like this is
[ __ ] i can just do tomorrow morning yeah
so now it's like i don't have to do it
now yeah i mean it's different like if
it's like friends i haven't seen in a
while i'll [ __ ] sleep oh yeah that is
like the one exception where i'm like
yeah i'll be happy like 5am if it's just
like a normal night out with these lads
who i see every week i'm like guys i'm
getting a bit tired
next week i'm like all right
true true i need a piss quickly oh my
god i'm sorry i didn't i didn't take one
last time when we had a long break this
man's woman bladder